hi my name is jeff goldblum jeff
goldblum
i'm a guest correspondent for wired and
i'm going to be reviewing and testing
some travel gadgets
[Music]
please may i have the first gadget
i'm being handed i don't like it already
but it's plasticky
what the heck is this this looks like an
you know something requiring an
embouchure
[Laughter]
you know that's like that's that's
christmas this thing releases
the hell is going on here world's
tiniest
vacuum
you say vacuum vacuum or vacuum usb
cable powered it has strong suction
power uh the less said about that the
better
a reusable filter love it
uh use it for crumbs on the shirt after
eating and it works perfectly and that's
an amazon customer and he or she uh gave
it five stars this is a joke for a
vacuum
terrible to suck up anything it's colby
c-o-l-b-i-e unusual spelling for colby i
would have gone with and i've known
other colby's c-o-l-b-y like the cheese
colby gives this one out of five stars
well wait a minute if they if colby
gives it one out of five stars and the
review is that bad it's terrible she
says to suck up anything how does that
rate a one why would she give it a one
is that you know being polite or
gracious or i give it zero if that's how
you feel about it give it zero i don't
understand this rating system
[Music]
here's my feeling
uh colby
you couldn't be more wrong in my humble
opinion you say it's terrible to suck up
anything it's fantastic at least if it
sprinkles on a plate uh you know there's
wet meat on a shag rug i don't know if
that would do anything with that
for sprinkles on a on a
glass plate a porcelain plate from ikea
ah
excellent it every single sprinkle it
didn't miss a sprinkle it did it in no
time at all
10 gold blooms out of a possible 10 gold
ones that's my feeling i'm going to be
handed the next gadget
thank you mr gadget pander okay
wow already uh this is called
pocket talk oh well here it is now that
i've turned it on i might have in one
more second realize this myself because
it says espanol spanish spain uh english
u.s with pocket talk a two-way voice
translator device you can travel to 133
countries around the world communicate
with conference you can accurately
translate up to 82 languages
even though they happen in 133 countries
i guess they've really figured that out
several of those countries speak the
same language and dialects in the palm
of your hand using the best
transcription and translation engines in
our library incredible real time
translator quote star trek in real life
and out of five possible stars you know
what he gives it five five stars one
man's trash is another man's treasure
well
delta tran starts off saying crap
crap won't even turn on now okay so
that's very clear one star does nobody
have the courage to give it no stars
my golly
hello device with a long name it just
translated what i said
excuse me um can i have that uh omelette
with no meat
mr waiter di
puedo
[Music]
my wife speaks french to the kids we've
got a couple of kids and she speaks
english beautifully and french
beautifully but she speaks kind of
exclusively french to the kids and i
speak ampatipe which means just a little
bit and so oftentimes
i feel a little bit you know like that i
could use this at home
i could use this at home
10 gold blooms out of a possible 10 gold
blooms
be quiet now how you shut the how you
shut the machine up
i like the way you handle it you could
work on um a wheel of fortune
what the heck is this well i the
graphics are interesting me well it
looks like a camera of some kind and
it's looks like it's for kids because
it's got that stuff
it's a gadget
i'm oh
maybe that's how you take a picture
maybe i go like this and i
i just heard i heard it click i think i
just took a picture of something paper
shoot camera that sounds like rock paper
scissors that sounds like some kind of
game these revolutionary digital cameras
take photos like a film camera uh giving
you that film aesthetic without having
to go through the trouble of developing
it you can simply upload all your images
to your computer for easy access i
dropped it in the toilet briefly
while high there's a lot of information
in that first sentence i'm not even done
with the sentence and it still works
some filters work way better in
different lighting carson w has um has
given it four out of five stars i can't
believe i waited six months for this toy
camera it takes photos but the quality
is not much better than an old
instamatic don't waste your time and
money oh by robert j this is robert j
doesn't want to reveal his last name
gives it one star
so for me to test what i would have to
test i'm not going to get high and i'm
not going to drop in the toilet that's
first of all who can i hear catherine
can i take a picture of you come here
watch this keep the cameras rolling for
heaven's sakes okay watch this watch
this okay okay hang on hang on
i've done it okay thank you catherine
big big hand for
catherine okay so um first of all my eye
and uh and sense of framing and
composition is impeccable i give myself
10 out of 10 goldens for the for the
choice of subject and for the framing
it's almost like citizen kane where i
include the ceiling in the shot
[Music]
i love it i love it i don't know what um
what robert j is talking about it looks
like an old instamatic i like it and
that's good enough for me i gave it i
give it 10 gold blooms out of a possible
10 gold ones next gadget please
this is the classic i believe this is
the tom cruise
you know
wait a minute something just dinged i
don't know if you heard it i heard it
ray-ban stories wayfair integrates the
best of your phone with the timeless
fram bringing you a new way to capture
and share your adventures ah
ah
comes with touch control
dual 5 mp
here we go again with the abbreviations
dual five more mp i'm gonna ask in a
second what that is camera audio
charging case my eye fell upon that
immediately and facebook
view
app first of all mp well i'm sure this
this techno crowd knows about what's
what's 5mp camera
megapixel
megapixel did everybody else know that
too
carlos wait excellent that's the review
and he gives it five stars
stopped working after a week of light
use
[Music]
uh
and they give it one star so there's all
that
i would test it but i i i still don't
know what to do with it what i got
okay so you're gonna put them on and
then there's a button right here okay so
so again we can test it okay uh once
again i need a volunteer catherine
please come join me on this set um
excuse me um i'm sorry what's your
what's your name catherine hi catherine
uh my name is jeff say um
do you know how to get to the um the
statue of liberty
just that way and then that way
hi catherine
my name is jeff fantastic first of all
so i love it i suppose you could put
this technology in any frame i myself uh
favor the giacomo image frame uh you
know of which i've you know with whom
i've collaborated we have the jeffs we
have so i myself am wearing the jeff now
so you could do this technology on the
jeff uh i wouldn't always use it in that
uh creepy fashion that i did
you know but it would be good for a lot
of uses i think that's creative
has created potential 10 gold blooms out
of a possible 10 goldblums i'm a
positive guy i give good reviews to
everything don't i please bring the
next gadget which is the final
gadget
[Music]
i love the way you do that that's
fantastic i love that what the heck is
this
well first of all there's a thing looks
like i'm to blow it up
no matter how far off the grid you go
the m-powered lucci outdoor 2.0
inflatable solar lantern keeps you out
of the dark for up to 24 hours between
charges and it's completely solar just
add sun
wow
the best this is my second lucci light
the first one lasted a decade and this
one will too
start that gives it uh
five stars i have a dud certainly it
holds air 12 plus hours solar input
holds no charge two hours best then
totally kaput denise gives a one star
she sounds like she's
she's talking about more than
just
you know gadgets here
okay so here we go
already that's about enough for me wait
a minute just a second
come on goldie let's go
and that's the old blonde that's the old
lung power that i knew was there hey and
that's from one lung power one will do
it that's already a good review for me i
thought i was gonna have to you know for
half an hour
one that's one gold bloom
all my gold bloom air is in that thing
right now hey this is now a little more
valuable than the than the simple device
right
wired team
can we please whoever's in charge of
this sort of thing can we please
dim the lights
yes further further as dim as you dare
fully dark
dark pitch black look okay look
horror movie love story
horror story love story you see the
lighting there there there
i love you my darling i love you
i'll get you yet i'll get you yet i love
you i love you so much you see what i
mean see how i see what you can do with
the lighting manipulating the lighting
well it's very bright it's very good
i love it this gets a full
another 10 goal i've given away
i don't know
[Music]
10 20 30 40 50 stars i mean gold blooms
i've given away all my gold blooms i
don't know how many gold blooms i have
in me i don't want to give away all my
gold ones but anyway that's there's the
thing and it looks very very you know i
wonder if you can get high and drop this
in the toilet too and what would happen
but
don't don't do that well anyway there we
go i like it
okay
well that's all five
gadgets so here's my question what did
you
think of those gadgets this is jeff
goldblum
wired correspondent
guest correspondent signing off
until i see you again signing out thank
you
[Music]